et l'endroit dans lequel il est retrouvé
va intrigué particulièrement la femme de
ménage son corps est retrouvé
en état de décomposition dans sa
baignoire
or le personnel de maison notamment la
femme de ménage attitré de Monsieur
Francesco nous a affirmé que celui-ci ne
prenait plus de bain depuis très
longtemps à son âge on se sert de douche
italienne mais on n'a pas le loisir
d'aller dans une baignoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
26 mai 2012 à Pau comme chaque semaine
Catherine appelle son père Robert
un appel qu'elle n'est pas prête
d'oublier j'appelle et c'est une voix de
femme inconnue qui me répond
allô elle me dit ben qu'elle va pas
pouvoir me parler parce que il est pas
bien depuis quelques jours il est alité
tout à l'heure je voudrais absolument
parler à mon père je vais quand même
demander de me passer mon père
j'aimerais bien lui parler de passer le
moi quand même il a bredouille des
choses incompréhensibles on voyait bien
qu'il avait la voix pâteuse complètement
pâteuse qui n'arrivait pas à articuler
je me dis c'est quand même bizarre mon
père il est il est jamais malade
qu'est-ce qui se passe quoi qu'est-ce
qui se passe
catherine est très inquiète son père a
87 ans et habite à 900 km de chez elle
Annemasse et surtout elle se demande qui
est la femme qui lui a répondu
elle décide donc d'appeler la police
j'ai appelé le commissariat de police
d'Annemasse j'ai expliqué donc ce que je
venais d'entendre et que j'étais
inquiète et que voilà je suis s'il
pouvait aller voir ce qui se passe ça
serait bien oui
en fait les craintes de Catherine vont
s'avérer fonder
les policiers vont se rendre assez
rapidement au domicile du vieux monsieur
ils arrivent sur le palier et à ce
moment-là la porte qui les intéresse
sans trouve ils aperçoivent furtivement
une femme qui dès qu'elle voit
l'uniforme referme la porte les
policiers ont le temps de mettre le pied
dans la porte pour empêcher donc qu'elle
se claque il rentre en force et ils sont
face à une femme d'une cinquantaine
d'années qui a une valise à la main qui
était sur le point de partir
cette femme qui tente de s'enfuir la
voici elle s'appelle Patricia Dagorn
les policiers l'interpellent éfouillent
l'appartement à la recherche du vieux
monsieur
il trouve le vieil homme au pied de son
lit comme s'il était tombé du lit
[Musique]
le vieil homme est dans un très mauvais
état
Gila dans sa saleté dans sa crasse au
milieu de ses excréments
il va pas bien du tout
les policiers appellent les secours et
place team immédiatement Patricia Dagorn
en garde à vue ils ignorent que c'est le
début d'une incroyable enquête une
affaire hors norme qui va révéler de
l'ours secret
sur le chemin de la mort il y a pas de
problème
[Musique]
les expertises toxicologiques révèlent
qu'il a absorbé une dose importante de
Valium
[Musique]
vous avez sauvé la vie de votre père
parce que votre père a été victime d'une
veuve noire
[Musique]
c'était le sexe
des hommes sont des
rotatives habillés à pognon
j'ai été vraiment dégoûté de
me dire que ça c'était ma mère
elle
montrera aucun signe de regret
[Musique]
donnons des bains Robert est entre la
vie et la mort en soins intensifs
les médecins essaient de comprendre ce
qui lui est arrivé et ce sont les
analyses toxicologiques qui vont
apporter un début de réponse un policier
appelle la fille de Robert pour lui
communiquer les résultats des analyses
il me dit et ben vous avez sauvé la vie
de votre père les expertises
toxicologiques révèlent qu'il a absorbé
une dose importante de valium les
expertises toxicologiques du sang et des
cheveux de Monsieur Robert ont révélé la
présence de diazépam substance
commercialisée sous le nom de valium et
susceptible de provoquer un fort
ralentissement psychomoteur et une
altération de la vigilance
c'est très curieux parce que Robert ne
s'est jamais fait prescrire ce produit
ce médicament ah non
non je pense qu'il en a jamais pris
mais ce n'est pas tout chose incroyable
le vieux monsieur a été violenté c'est
l'examen médical qui va révéler ce que
l'on peut qualifier de maltraitance
Robert a été violenté porte des traces
des petits mots
c'est un vieux monsieur qui est en très
très mauvais état
c'est un cauchemar et là je me dis que
il y a quelque chose de grave
[Musique]
lisonquêteurs en sont convaincus Robert
a été empoisonné et maltraitée et il
soupçonne fortement Patricia Dagorn la
femme qu'ils ont interpellé d'être
impliqués dans cette affaire
et c'est en fouillant sa valise que
leurs soupçons vont se confirmer
les policiers découvrent 7 flacons de
Valium
quand on sait qu'il a ingurgité une dose
massive de valium et qu'on retrouve ces
mêmes produits dans la valise de
Patricia lagorne le lien est
relativement vite fait mais face aux
enquêteurs Patricia Dagorn se montre sur
d'elle et semble avoir réponse à tout
elle raconte d'abord qu'en réalité c'est
elle qui prend le Valium
c'est elle qui en consommait qui s'en
était faite prescrire pour se détendre à
une époque elle a eu des angoisses et
donc elle avait récupéré ses flacons
auprès de médecins et elle avait des
ordonnances sur elle Patricia Dagorn
raconte que Robert a avalé à son insu le
Valium lors du dîner qui a eu lieu
quelques heures plus tôt au menu il y
avait du riz avec du saumon la limite
quelques gouttes de valium dans son
assiette et elle dit que la seule
explication pour que Robert en est
absorbé c'est qu'il a dû lui prendre son
assiette quelque chose de complètement
illogique si vous voulez
le problème c'est que l'état de santé de
Robert ne correspond pas avec
l'absorption d'une dose unique de valium
en fait ça correspond plutôt à un
empoisonnement important continue
répéter
tout aussi facilement Patricia Dagor
n'explique les nombreux hématomes que
l'on retrouve sur le corps du vieil
homme
Patricia Dagorn ni avec véhémence toute
maltraitance sur Robert elle ne l'a pas
violenté en fait pour elle il serait
tombé tout seul
elle a indiqué que Robert pouvait à de
nombreuses reprises lui-même chutées
clairement les marques qu'on avait
retrouvé sur verre pouvait tout à fait
correspondre à une simple chute
accidentelle
et ce n'est pas tout les enquêteurs
retrouvent dans les affaires de Patricia
Dagorne une carte bancaire au nom de
Robert ainsi que le chéquier du vieil
homme
mais là encore elle a une explication
Patricia explique que c'est Robert qui
lui a donné le chéquier pour qu'elle
aille faire les courses du couple
seulement Patricia Dagorn peine à
convaincre les policiers
d'autant qu'ils vont découvrir qu'elle
est arrivée très récemment dans la vie
de Robert leur liaison semble avoir
débuté six jours plus tôt robert est un
vieil homme en octogénaire en mal
d'amour il vit loin de sa fille qui vit
à 900 km de lui à Pau et il croise la
route de Patricia Dagorn le 20 mai 2012
il a vu cette femme qui attendait devant
un hôtel social il y a eu un échange de
regard de sourire et c'est elle qui
l'aborde en lui disant qu'elle n'est pas
d'ici qu'elle vient d'arriver qu'elle
cherche un toit qu'elle cherche un
endroit pour dormir
et mon père lui dit bah écoutez j'ai un
grand appartement j'ai une chambre que
je peux mettre à votre disposition en
attendant que vous trouviez quelque
chose que vous réglez votre problème
le vieil homme propose donc d'aider
Patricia Dagorn gratuitement enfin
presque car Robert va fixer une
condition
toute particulière il va lui proposer de
l'héberger mais avec une petite
condition suspensive c'est qu'ils aient
des relations intimes
il échange l'hébergement contre des
rapports sexuels
pour Robert rencontrer une
femme en temps de moins que lui
c'est bien oui pour lui c'est bien bon
c'est sûr qui a été un peu jeune enfin
c'est bien bon ça faisait 5 ou 6 ans
qu'il était veuve qui souffrait de la
solitude donc bah oui s'il pouvait
rencontrer quelqu'un
avec qui s'entendent bien qui qui
s'occupe de lui qui comble un peu sa
solitude etc c'est très bien oui
qui est certain au regard de leur
parcours
respectifs c'est qu'ils étaient très
seuls et on demande d'affection et l'un
et l'autre ont pu trouver dans cette
rencontre un moyen de mettre un terme à
leur solitude
le soir même de leur rencontre Patricia
Dagan s'installe donc chez Robert
m'aider le lendemain l'attitude de la
quincagénaire va changer du tout au tout
l'accompagner mon père à la banque pour
qu'il retire de l'argent avec la carte
bleue donc là il lui a fait rediriger
600 euros
Patricia essaye d'utiliser la carte de
Robert pour retirer de l'argent et en
fait elle bloque la carte
alors elle va contacter la banque
demander une nouvelle carte un nouveau
code confidentiel et en fait son but
c'est d'accéder au compte courant de
Robert et à sa fortune
manifestement Patricia Dagorn n'était
plus intéressé par l'argent de Robert
que par l'homme
à l'hôpital d'Annemasse le vieil homme
hospitalisé se réveille enfin et
interrogé par une grande radio nationale
il raconte le calvaire que Patricia
Dagorn lui a fait vivre
violemment sur le sol et la tiré le bras
d'un coup elle m'a fait tomber en bas du
lit sur le dos des coups de poing comme
un fait très mal et je suis toujours pas
en forme
il dit qu'elle a pas qu'elle a pas été
gentille que très vite effectivement
elle lui a donné des ordres elle lui a
demandé de faire des choses qui
voulaient pas forcément faire et que à
la fin elle a carrément
malmenée puisque elle l'a fait tomber du
lit en tirant le drap elle a pas du tout
été gentille avec nous et Robert
ajoutera j'ai failli mourir pour
quelques jours d'amour
[Musique]
lorsque Catherine la fille de Robert
arrive au chevet de son père elle
réalise qu'il est passé à côté du pire
quand je l'ai vu effectivement je me
suis dit que je sais même pas s'il
aurait passé la nuit c'est-à-dire qu'il
était complètement déshydraté dénutri il
avait plus qu'à peau sur les os j'ai
compris oui que que la situation avait
été très grave avec
je fais du sérieux oui
[Musique]
Patricia Dagorn est placé en détention
provisoire à la prison de
Thonon-les-Bains elle est mise en examen
pour empoisonnement et maltraitant
cependant et malgré les éléments qu'il
accuse elle clament son innocence avec
force depuis sa prison elle va écrire
des centaines de lettres à tous ses
proches en voici un extrait
le pire est que je n'y suis pour rien
dans ce qui s'est produit ça je te le
jure un vieux est tombé à côté de son
lit et apporter plainte et me voilà
accuser de non-assistance à personne en
danger et on me met tout sur le dos je
n'avais fait qu'une escale chez cette
personne et en rentrant chez lui je le
retrouve par terre
alors qui est cette femme que tout
semble accusé et qui clame son innocence
les policiers sont loin d'imaginer ce
qu'ils vont découvrir en fouillant le
passé de la quinquagénaire un passé
particulièrement trouble
Patricia Dagorn n'a pas eu une enfant
heureuse c'est le moi que l'on puisse
dire elle est née dans une famille assez
pauvre avec un peralcoolique qui ne l'a
pas reconnu et qui s'est montré violent
dès les premiers temps de sa vie
dès l'âge de 6 ans patricia a été placé
dans des familles d'accueil
donc dès l'origine on a une situation
qui a été très précaire pour Patricia
Dagorn une précarité qu'on va retrouver
tout au long de sa vie elle-même ayant
dû faire face à des situations
difficiles avec ses compagnons puis
ensuite avec ses enfants
l'homme qui a marqué les jeunes années
de Patricia Dagorn le voici il s'appelle
Luc Caron et a partagé sa vie pendant 23
ans
le temps a passé mais il garde en
mémoire le jour de leur première
rencontre quand j'ai rencontré Patricia
le 19 février 1982 à 19h45 je crois que
c'était un vendredi
j'ai cru que le soleil arrivé sur moi
c'était magnifique
Patricia
c'est une gueule d'ange sur un corde
démon
[Musique]
elle avait 22 ans et moi un peu plus de
35 ans j'étais amoureux fou
Luc Caron a une personnalité
assez singulière
lorsqu'il se rend compte avec Patricia
Dagorn il se présente comme magnétiseur
comme
voyant comme psychothérapeute au final
comme escroc
le couple file le parfait amour et
s'installe dans le Gers
ils auront deux garçons
j'ai été très heureux avec Patricia très
heureux mon dernier moment heureux avec
Patricia c'était la naissance de Guilhem
après ça a été la déglingue complète
car un soir de mars 1992 l'histoire
d'amour va tourner au cauchemar le car
on rentre chez lui totalement
ivre et pour une raison inexpliquée il
devient fou
[Musique]
j'ai pété un câble quoi et là ce jour-là
parce que j'ai complètement déconnecté
je ne me suis réveillé que trois jours
après
l'homme s'en est pris avec une violence
inouïe à sa femme et à ses deux enfants
je sais pas ce que j'ai fait ni comment
je l'ai fait
et sauf qu'on m'a arrêté comme on est en
prison quoi
le carreau est arrêté et condamné le 8
avril 1993 à 11 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour acte de barbarie sur sa
compagne et leurs deux enfants
mais contre toute attente Patricia
Dagorn ne va pas le quitter elle va même
régulièrement lui rendre visite à la
maison d'arrêt de Saint-Martin de Ré
vous allez voir papa à l'époque elle est
suivie par des caméras de télévision
pour un reportage sur les lieux
d'hébergement des familles de détenus
[Musique]
pour moi la possibilité en fait de
pouvoir voir mon mari régulièrement
sinon je pouvais pas quand on arrive ici
on se retrouve en commun avec des gens
qui ont vécu la même chose que nous en
fait
trois ans après les faits alors qu'il
est toujours en prison Patricia Dagorn
décide d'épouser le carreau
c'est là qu'on voit que la relation
entre Luc Caron et Patricia Dagorn était
étrange pourquoi se marier avec son
bourreau
elle a un lien qualifié de pathologique
à l'égard de cet homme
à sa sortie de prison en 2002 lucaron
regagne le domicile conjugal l'homme est
à nouveau très violent à tel point que
Guilhem le plus jeune des enfants en
sera marqué à jamais nous l'avons
retrouvé et il a accepté de témoigner
j'ai vécu le retour de mon père à la
maison comme une période très effrayante
il y avait beaucoup de tension dans la
maison à l'époque que je souhaitais
quand même protéger ma mère et c'était
une menace pour moi c'était une mauvaise
période
pour Patricia Dagorn s'en est trop elle
décide de tout plaquer et demande le
divorce pendant près de 10 ans elle ne
fait plus parler d'elle jusqu'à son
arrestation en 2012 pour la faire de
Robert Annemasse mais son histoire ne
s'arrête pas là car elle cache bien
d'autres secrets
en fouillant la valise de Patricia
Dagorn lors de son arrestation les
policiers ont fait une autre découverte
capitale des documents plutôt
d'inquiétant
les policiers découvrent dans la valise
de Patricia Dagorne une quantité
incroyable de papier qui concerne
d'autres hommes c'est tous des documents
officiels des photocopies de carte
d'identité des cartes bleues des Ribes
même des testaments alors il y a
certains de ces documents au nom de
Robert d'Annemasse mais aussi des
documents au nom d'une dizaine d'autres
personnes
alors Patricia Dagor n'aurait été
l'empoisonné d'autres hommes que Robert
et bien cela n'est peut-être pas
impossible on se rend compte que deux
hommes sont morts sur la Côte d'Azur
dans des circonstances un peu suspectes
et ces deux hommes on a retrouvé des
papiers à leur nom dans les affaires de
Patricia Dagorn
le premier nom trouvé dans les affaires
de Patricia Dagorne et sur lequel les
policiers vont enquêter et celui de
Michel knifel le 23 juillet 2011
à Nice dans un petit hôtel près de la
gare on découvre le cadavre de Michel
knessel
l'homme a une soixantaine d'années il
vit dans une petite chambre d'un hôtel
minable ce jour-là les policiers
retrouveront près de la victime Patricia
Dagorn qui se présentera comme étant la
compagne de Michel knifel
Michel knifel est un compagnon
d'infortune de Madame d'accordme c'est
un sans domicile fixe ils gèrent tous
les deux dans la ville
l'hotelier sera entendu par la police et
expliquera dans quel état il a vu
arriver le matin même Michel knifel qui
n'était apparemment pas dans son
assiette au bras de Patricia Dagorn
Michel présente des symptômes de fatigue
sérieuse il est pas en bon état il est
pas en bonne santé il arrivait même pas
à porter sa valise il a échoué dans
cette chambre d'hôtel
Ier
déclare avoir vu monsieur knifel montait
en titulant les escaliers un pas
chancelant puis madame Dagorne l'enferme
dans la chambre d'hôtel
elle est revenue vers 23h 23h30 et là
elle le découvre comme ça face contre
terre dans une mare de sang c'est elle
qui a prévenu les policiers cette
affaire a été classée par le par les
autorités comme une mort naturelle ils
avaient diagnostiqué une embolie
pulmonaire et aucune enquête
supplémentaire n'avait été diligente
en effet à l'époque l'autopsie pratiquée
sur Michel knifel avait révélé la
présence de valium dans son sang
mais pas en quantité suffisante pour
provoquer sa mort
un taux supérieur à 5000 nanogrammes par
millilitre peut être mortel le sang de
Michel kneefel contient 448 nanogrammes
par millilitre le taux retrouvé dans le
sang de Monsieur knifel et 10 fois
inférieur auto mortel
il est impossible et un Soto là de
porter atteinte à la vie de Monsieur
knifère alors la mort de Michel knifel
était-elle vraiment naturelle ce dossier
n'aurait-il pas à l'époque été classé un
peu trop vite c'est la question que se
pose aujourd'hui les policiers
la mort de Monsieur knifel devient
suspecte parce que finalement quand bien
même les analystes toxicologiques avec
le mélange du valium et de l'alcool
aurait pu conduire à une mort naturelle
les enquêteurs font le parallèle avec
l'affaire d'Annemasse lui-même
empoisonné au Valium
toutefois une incertitude demeure
qu'elle aurait été le mobile de Patricia
Dagorn pour tuer Michel nefel car
l'homme n'a pas un sou les choses sont
claires dès l'origine vu que nephael il
n'a rien il n'a rien à léguer
à Nice les enquêteurs poursuivent leurs
investigations et ils ne sont pas au
bout de leur surprise car il découvre
que Patricia Dagorn s'était inscrite
trois mois après la mort de Michel
knifel dans une agence matrimoniale
le parcours de vie de Patricia lagrande
est marqué par la solitude un moment
donné
l'inscription dans une agence
matrimoniale lui apparaît comme la moyen
de rompre cette solitude et de faire des
rencontres qu'elle n'arrive pas à faire
dans son quotidien et aussi incroyable
que cela puisse paraître pour trouver
l'âme sœur Patricia Dagorn va s'inventer
un personnage qu'elle n'est pas Patricia
Dagorn se présente comme une femme
d'affaires bijoutière diamantaire alors
qu'elle a jamais eu une activité de
joaillerie voici l'annonce que Patricia
Dagorn avait rédigé
51 ans nouvellement installé dans la
région elle est diamantaire de formation
jolie bien faite un bon discours une
intelligence vive aime particulièrement
la mer et le soleil les beaux endroits
et les intérieurs douillets où elle peut
recevoir et cuisiner elle sera la
compagnie des Halles et attentionnée que
vous attendez
dans son annonce effectivement elle
elle laisse transparaître ses rêves mais
c'était aussi un moyen pour elle de
pouvoir sur ton nez vers des hommes qui
correspondaient pour elle au profil d'un
homme qui pouvait la sécuriser et la
sécurité Patricia Dagorn l'imagine avec
un profil d'homme bien particulier
elle demande à rencontrer exclusivement
des hommes beaucoup plus âgés qu'elle
elle demande à rencontrer des hommes
âgés de 80 ans et plus
c'est étonnant parce que à cette époque
là elle a quand même une cinquantaine
d'années et des hommes si possible avec
une fortune personnelle une fois qu'elle
avait une cible précise sa monnaie
d'échange c'était le sexe elle offrait
des rapports sexuels à ces hommes en
contrepartie desquelles il devait bien
évidemment lui offrir le gîte et le
couvert mais aussi
participer à ces projets financiers
et parmi les rencontres que Patricia
Dagorn a faite dans cette agence
matrimoniale
les enquêteurs découvrent qu'un autre
homme est mort de façon suspecte
le 8 février 2011 on découvre le cadavre
de Francesco à Monsieur de 86 ans il est
en état de décomposition dans sa
baignoire et c'est sa femme de ménage
qui va découvrir le corps de de ce vieux
monsieur
comme Francesco Filippo et diabétique et
cardiaque sa mort et là encore à
l'époque considéré comme naturel et
classé sans suite
mais aujourd'hui des enquêteurs ne
voient pas les choses sous le même
prisme
c'est un homme qui vit seul depuis le
décès de sa femme en 2008 ses enfants
habitent loin il était il habite une
belle maison à Mont Sartoux c'est un
homme riche
c'est donc la proie idéale pour Madame
d'accordne Francisco cet Italien est un
homme qui prend soin de lui toujours
tiré à quatre épingles plutôt charmeur
pour son âge il est quand même plus de
80 ans Francesco et veuf depuis 4 ans il
cherche activement une nouvelle compagne
il s'est inscrit dans la même agence
matrimoniale que Patricia Dagorn et ils
vont se rencontrer en janvier 2011
monsieur Francesco qui est un homme en
possession de toutes ces facultés
physiques a envie d'avoir une compagne
pour aussi avoir des relations sexuelles
leur idylle va durer quelques jours
elle dort chez lui elle passe du temps
avec lui et là encore le scénario se
répète en quelques jours l'état de santé
de Francesco se dégrade et comme par
hasard c'est justement pendant qu'il
entretient une relation avec Patricia
Dagorn quelques jours avant sa mort
monsieur Francesco vient consulter son
médecin traitant
ce médecin qui est habitué à avoir un
homme sur de lui en pleine forme voit un
homme à moins de riz qui qui a une
démarche un peu chancelante il nous
exprime que finalement tout pourrait
laisser à penser à un abus de
médicaments
très vite les proches de Francesco vont
remarquer que quelque chose cloche car
au-delà de son état de santé c'est la
femme qui dorénavant vie chez lui qui
pose question
le 27 janvier 2011 la femme de ménage
qui a l'habitude de passer chez
Francesco viens chez lui
[Musique]
elle a été
reçu par une femme qui lui a dit que
c'était pas la peine de rentrer quand on
n'avait pas besoin d'elle cette femme ne
peut être que Patricia Lagarde
la semaine suivante la femme de ménage
revient
elle trouve porte close et donc inquiète
elle décide d'appeler les secours
en réalité
Francesco est mort depuis plusieurs
jours et l'endroit dans lequel il est
retrouvé va intrigué particulièrement la
femme de ménage son corps est retrouvé
en état de décomposition dans sa
baignoire
or le personnel de maison notamment la
femme de ménage attitrée de Monsieur
Francesco nous a affirmé que celui-ci ne
prenait plus de bain depuis très
longtemps à son âge on se sert de douche
italienne mais on n'a pas le loisir
d'aller dans une baignoire
à l'époque les interrogations de la
femme de ménage ne seront pas prises en
compte
et si le cas de Francesco ressemble
beaucoup à celui de Robert danemas les
enquêteurs ne peuvent désormais pas
aller plus loin dans leurs
investigations et pour cause le problème
c'est que le corps a été très rapidement
incinéré donc il est impossible de
réaliser des analyses toxicologiques
complémentaires donc on ne peut pas
prouver s'il y a eu des traces de valium
dans son organisme
coïncidence troublante le jour de la
mort de Francesco
Patricia Dagorn a touché une importante
somme d'argent
ce qui laisse supposé l'implication de
Madame Dagorne dans le meurtre de
Monsieur Francesco c'est que le jour de
son décès soit le premier février 2011
madame Dagorn encaisse un chèque de
21000 euros
ce qui est étonnant dans le comportement
de Monsieur Francesco c'est que ce
monsieur est connu comme étant quelqu'un
de pingre proche de ses sous bien qu'il
en est et puis sa rencontre avec Madame
dagorg le fait dépenser de manière
inconsidérée son argent alors que ce
n'est pas du tout une habitude chez ce
monsieur confronté à ces nouvelles
accusations
Patricia Dagorn continue depuis sa
cellule donc la maison
elle va d'ailleurs écrire à son ex-mari
lucaron qu'elle n'est pour rien dans la
mort de Francesco et voici ce qu'elle
lui dit
ma rencontre avec Francesco à Cannes une
rencontre très courte dans le temps très
distante je l'avais quitté très vite à
cause de l'incompatibilité de son âge et
du mien je l'ai quitté vivant et je n'ai
appris son décès que plus tard par son
fils mais nous étions tombés d'accord
pour nous associer pour reprendre la
gérance de cette petite boutique de
joaillerie Francesco m'avait fait un
chèque de 21000 € j'avais gardé ce
chèque et je suis rentrée à Cannes où
j'ai déposé ce chèque en ignorant
totalement le décès de Francesco
Patricia Dagorn explique qu'elle a
quitté Francesco à cause de leur trop
grande différence d'âge le jour de sa
mort elle est à Cannes et elle a
encaissé ce chèque mais c'est une
coïncidence et les policiers là comment
ça se dire ça fait beaucoup de quoi
incidence et il se demande si ce n'est
pas vraiment une femme dangereuse
pour l'ex-mari Patricia Dagorn est avant
tout une femme vénale
patricia est une affairiste pas une
femme d'affaire mais il a fait rire dans
le sens où elle
la trappe tout ce qui peut passer à sa
portée qui fait son affaire à elle
10 euros par là 500 euros par là 1000
euros par ci ça oui
elle saute sur les occasions
[Musique]
des hommes sont des
rotatives habillés à argent Afrique à
pognon
c'est
l'art
la matière première pour faire du fric
c'est tout c'est rien d'autre
et cela Luc Caron n'est pas le seul à le
penser
en décembre 2011 et ma présenté ce vieil
homme qui qui était très sympa qui qui
nous a payé le restaurant
et quand il est allé vers la caisse elle
m'a dit t'inquiète cet homme là je ne
l'aime pas
j'en veux qu'à son argent
é de
me dire que ça c'était ma mère
Patricia Dagorn serait donc une femme
vénale pour autant est-elle une mante
religieuse qui empoisonnerait ses amants
pour leur soutirer de l'argent en tout
cas pour les enquêteurs les similitudes
entre les cas de Robert
Francesco et Michel nefel laisse penser
qu'elle a mis au point un véritable mode
opératoire
finalement on se demande vraiment si
cette femme n'est pas une manipulatrice
une prédatrice c'est une prédatrice dans
la mesure où elle cherche toujours le
même profil d'homme des hommes
vulnérables
âgés et se les et qui sont dans une
profonde misère affective seulement les
policiers n'ont aucune preuve formelle
c'est un dossier qui est extrêmement
fragile c'est un dossier d'impression
c'est un dossier de nuances et c'est en
tout cas ça repose sur rien de concret
alors pour tenter de confondre Patricia
Dagorn les policiers vont adopter une
autre méthode
le 16 novembre 2013 la police judiciaire
de Nice décide de passer un appel à
témoin dans la presse locale on y voit
la photo de Patricia Dagorn au moment où
elle a été interpellée et on explique
que cette femme est soupçonnée
d'empoisonnement sur personne
vulnérables en fait on essaye de voir
s'il y a pas d'autres victimes dans le
cadre d'une information judiciaire
ouverte à Nice pour assassinat
empoisonnement avec préméditation
administration de substances nuisibles
volent facilité par l'état d'une
personne vulnérable la brigade
criminelle de la police judiciaire de
Nice demande à toutes les personnes
victimes des agissements de cette femme
dont la photo est publiée de la
contacter
fait appel à témoin
a été passé dans le cadre d'une
publication d'un journal beaucoup plus
large avec en gros titre l'empoisonneuse
de la Riviera c'est une empoisonneuse si
vous l'avez rencontré vous êtes
certainement l'une de ces victimes
manifestez-vous
mais cet appel à témoin ne va rien
donner
[Musique]
donc les policiers vont fouiller dans
les archives de l'agence matrimoniale
pour essayer de voir qui est rentré en
contact avec Patricia lagorne et les
enquêteurs vont tomber sur cet homme lui
aussi s'appelle Robert il a vécu trois
mois avec Patricia et c'est qu'elle a
tenté de l'empoisonner mais il n'a
jamais porté plainte
c'est un octogénaire là encore mais
encore vif encore actif il est très
entouré bon il a perdu sa femme quelques
années auparavant et il se sent très
seul il a vraiment envie de rencontrer
quelqu'un de partager sa vie avec
quelqu'un
[Musique]
vous savez
au début de l'hiver afin de l'automne
comment se faire froid
vous avez tendance de freiner votre pape
computer sur une soirée vous savez que
ça va pas durer et vous voulez en
profiter que vous voyez une femme qui
est beaucoup plus jeune que vous mais
que sympathique vous n'êtes pas maso il
est pas refusé ce moment agréable voilà
c'était un rayon de soleil affectif
simplement
robert est un homme qui a tout pour
plaire à Patricia Dagorn c'est un homme
qui a une bonne situation et il possède
un grand appartement à Fréjus et au
moment où il rencontre Patricia Dagorn
il va bientôt
hériter d'un bien immobilier de la part
de sa sœur
c'est quelqu'un qui a de l'argent qui a
un héritage il est vraiment la proie
idéal pour cette femme
elle voit certainement chez cet homme la
possibilité d'avoir ce qu'elle espérait
tant donc effectivement elle va demander
à Robert de lui faire profiter de ça
parce que c'est ce dont elle a manqué
depuis sa naissance encore une fois
auprès de Robert Patricia Dagand se
montre très intéressé par l'argent
à mon Robert que j'aime pour toujours je
reviens toujours vers toi
le compte accrédité pour le cas où tu
voudrais vraiment m'aider merci à toi
[Musique]
mille fois 150 000 des fois 10000 fois
1500% l'ordinateur
il faut être somme des fois des grosses
sommes
c'est fréquent de demain
rebuter pas
Robert refuse les demandes d'argent de
Patricia et il raconte que sa santé se
dégrade
[Musique]
alors lui comme les autres assez
rapidement ils se sont fatigués et il
chavirent le soir tout de suite après le
repas
il a parfois même pas le temps d'aller
jusqu'à son lit tellement il est fatigué
ce qui est quelque chose de nouveau dans
la vie de ce monsieur lorsqu'il
fréquente
son entourage son voisinage se rend
compte que cet homme toujours
dynamique avec le sourire comment ça
s'éteindre progressivement
quand j'étais avec elle je titube et
et un ami mais qu'est-ce qu'il a Robert
est il tue il marche pas tu le Soignes
ou quoi elle a répondu je lui donne des
vitamines c'était drôle de vitamines
qu'elle me donnait
au moment où il fréquente Patricia
Dagorne Robert se comporte bizarrement
comme s'il était drogué
alors la caca génère lui aurait-elle
donné du valium pour ensuite lui
soutirer de l'argent exactement comme
elle l'aurait fait pour les autres
victimes
[Musique]
on est dans les nuages et je me rendais
pas compte le 6 avril Robert consulte
son médecin
va faire une prise de sang et là on va
découvrir qu'il a une dose importante de
valium dans le sang or monsieur ne prend
pas de valeur son médecin traitant le
suit depuis de nombreuses années jamais
il ne lui a prescrit du Valium
évidemment ça pose problème
en fait Robert le sait aujourd'hui
Patricia en voulait à son argent
elle a écrit dans la même semaine deux
fois au notaire pour que je la fasse
légataire universel je lui laisse la
gestion pardon la jouissance de mon
appartement
et la procuration la gestion de mes
comptes bancaires
évidemment mon notaire m'a convoqué et
on a convenu d'un accord commun que
surtout pas céder
Robert est parfaitement alerte il est
parfaitement en forme il a toute sa tête
et il dit clairement son notaire moi je
ne modifierai pas mon testament
Robert commence à se méfier de Patricia
Dagorn et 15 jours plus tard il va faire
une découverte qui va le convaincre de
la quitter définitivement
Robert découvre qu'elle a passé une
annonce dans une agence patrimoniale en
Suisse donc elle continue sa prospection
de vieux monsieur et comme il est jaloux
il décide de rompre définitivement
madame monsieur je recherche un très
beau mariage en Suisse avec une personne
âgée
la colère m'a pris je te fous dehors
j'avais des doutes déjà mais ça va
confirmé que c'était perdre les mains
grossièreté mais elle est partie
à ce moment-là Robert l'ignore mais il
vient de se sauver la vie j'ai tellement
danger de mort il y avait une
continuation de valium évidemment elle
serait mort et dans l'état où j'étais
j'aurai une mort très douce j'étais sur
le chemin de la mort il y a pas de
problème et beaucoup Robert tu viens de
loin tu aurais été la plus belle voilà
lorsque Robert apprend que Patricia
Dagorn aurait fait d'autres victimes il
décide de porter plainte
le fils de Francesco Philippon s'associe
à lui dans le rang des participes
[Musique]
Patricia Dagorn et d'accuser
d'assassinat
d'empoisonnement avec préméditation
d'administration de substances nuisibles
à une personne vulnérable
Patricia Dagorn fait alors les gros
titres de la presse locale elle y est
présentée comme l'empoisonneuse de la
Riviera
[Musique]
son ex-mari Luc Caron ne fait pas qu'à
créditer cette version il va même
beaucoup plus loin pour lui Patricia
aurait même tué sa propre mère en 1991
pour récupérer son argent
sur sa mère a donné la mort
pour l'argent
parce qu'il y avait un ami en France
et on en a parlé ça
en a fait du million de France mais pour
elle c'était d'abord l'argent
la mère on s'en fout
une accusation que Patricia Dagorn
dément avec véhémence et pour laquelle
elle n'a jamais été inquiétée
que Luc Caron avait seul encaissé
l'argent
issu de l'assurance vie concernant sa
maman lucaron a eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer et de confirmer qu'il avait
investi cet argent dans l'achat d'une
belle voiture de luxe
force est de constatée qu'à aucun moment
une enquête a été ouverte pour
investiguer sur ces faits ni à la
demande de celui qui aujourd'hui
l'accuse ni par la justice elle-même il
agit sur elle un peu comme un
manipulateur on en est même à se
demander si il n'a pas créé le monstre
qu'elle est devenue je ne suis ni Dieu
ni Satan donc je peux pas créer
quelqu'un qui est déjà
si elle est comme elle est ce qu'elle
était déjà comme ça la relation entre
Patricia Dagorn et son ex-conjoint fait
froid dans le dos
le seul lien qui les relie c'est un lien
de haine leur relation est malsaine et
je pense que cet homme
est certainement pour beaucoup dans la
déchéance de Madame Dagorn la vérité
c'est que
mes dépenses sont comportées très mal
que ma mère a fait des choses très
graves que qu'elle mérite d'être en
prison aucun des deux ne dira la vérité
le procès de Patricia Dagorn s'ouvre le
15 janvier 2018 devant la Cour d'assise
de Nice la quinquagénaire est notamment
accusé de l'assassinat de Michel knifel
et de Francesco Philippon
d'empoisonnement avec préméditation et
d'administration de substances nuisibles
à une personne vulnérable elle risque 30
années de réclusion criminelle
est ouverte vous pouvez vous asseoir
la femme qui se présente dans le box des
accusés n'a plus rien d'une grande
séductrice
physiquement Patricia Dagorn c'est une
femme frêle les cheveux grisonnants de
petite taille elle ne ressemblent pas à
une séductrice comme on pourrait
l'imaginer quand on parle
d'empoisonneuse cinquantenaire qui
séduit des hommes plus âgés c'est
vraiment une femme simple quand j'ai vu
Patricia au tribunal dans le box des
accusés
ça m'a fait tout bizarre et en même
temps ça m'a fait du bien
moi je veux que elle avoue ce qu'elle a
fait pour moi tout ce dont on l'accuse
elle est coupable
les débats vont durer quatre jours
quatre jours pendant lesquels Patricia
Dagor n'a choisi de livrer sa vérité
le comportement de Madame Dagorn durant
les quatre jours de procès et
déstabilisant déstabilisant parce que
vous avez une femme qui a réponse à tout
à toutes les questions qui lui sont
posées madame Dagorn n'est jamais
décontenancé
elle n'éprouve aucune empathie envers
ses victimes elle elle est dans le déni
et elle conteste tout
lors de ces auditions madame Dagorn ne
vacille pas elle est impassible elle ne
semble avoir
aucun remord éprouvé aucun regret elle
ne
montrera aucun signe de regret
Patricia Dagorn fait à nouveau les gros
titres de la presse
coupable ou innocentes en tout cas les
experts psychiatres dressent un portrait
de la quinquagénaire pour le moins
inquiétant
elle présente une personnalité
pathologique instable narcissique et
psychotique avec un discours et des
propos évocateurs d'une mythomanie
madame Dagorn présente une dangerosité
potentielle extrêmement importante
le 18 janvier 2018 au terme de 4 jours
de procès Patricia Dagorn n'est condamné
à 22 ans de prison pour son fils Guilhem
c'est une véritable libération
très contente
parce que c'est une fille ou une
personne menaçante
si on la laisse dehors elle risque
vraiment de continuer
tant qu'à l'époque guérit mentalement
continuera à vouloir poursuivre son rêve
en faisant du mal autour d'elle
faire du mal ça la dérange pas
Patricia Dagorn clame toujours son
innocence elle a décidé de faire appel
de sa condamnation elle reste donc
présumée innocente son nom continue
d'apparaître dans les journaux mais elle
a rubrique rencontre car chose
totalement incroyable elle continue à
chercher le prince charmant
je suis seule et divorcée depuis 2005 je
ne pense qu'à refaire ma vie sur le plan
de ma personnalité je suis très
sentimentale et attachée aux vrais
valeurs si cette notion d'être deux unis
dans la fidélité et le respect mutuel de
l'autre vous convient aussi c'est avec
le plus grand plaisir que je ferai votre
connaissance à l'issue de cette durée
preuve la femme que je suis renaîtra
dans vos bras
[Musique]